تتغير الوان مدينه خيرسون فمنذ تحريرها
داب الاوكرانيون على ازاله اللوحات
الاعلانيه الروسيه ذات اللون الاحمر
والابيض والازرق
واستبدلوها برسائل الوطنيه
ذات المرئيه مهمه لانه اثناء الاحتلال
استخدم الروس اللوحات الاعلانيه لفرد
رسائلهم على سكان
ارادوا اثبته وجودهم لقد شاهدت ذلك في
التلفاز وعلى اللوحات الاعلانيه التي كانت
موجوده في كل مكان
في وسط خيرسون لوحه تحمل رساله للسكان
اعلان مختلف لمشكله اخرى ياخذوا محو
الاثار الروسيه اشكالا عده احدهما البحث
عن المتعاونين او الخونه كما يسميهم هذا
الاعلان باستخدام هذا الرمز يمكن الاتصال
بمنظمه استقصائيه تجمع المعلومات عنهم
وتنشره»
غير الحكوميه
كميه البيانات التي لدينا ضخمه نحن نتحدث
وليس فقط عن المتعاونين من الاراضي
المحتله المؤقته ولكن ايضا عن السياحه
الذين يحاولون تشويها سمعتهم
لا تعمل بشكل مباشر مع السلطه ولكن
اهدافهاما غالبا ما تكون مشتركا
اوليكساندر جون ديون في القوات الخاصه
مطارده المتعاونين مع روسيا هي احدى
المهام التي يقوم بها
معلمي المدارس في خرسن الذين كانوا على
استعدادا للتعاون مع السلطات الروسيه
من روسيا وشبه جزيره العرب